hallo
herzlich willkommen in meiner torten
welt heute mache ich einen sketch den
taten und zwar ist es dass zwischen
töpfchen dass ich nämlich dass bestimmte
aktien was ich bei den topfgeldjäger in
meiner ersten folge gemacht habe dort
hatte ich auch den leichten versprecher
mit dem zweiten taktierten falls ihr
euch erinnert und dieses rezept wollte
ich jetzt endlich für euch nach machen
ich habe die ganze zeit keine zwischen
gefunden aus dem tiefkühlfach
und jetzt hat mir meine mama gästen aus
dem garten mitgebracht habe ich gedacht
jetzt musst du endlich den kuchen machen
den habe ich jetzt heute für euch
gemacht in der sendung habe ich ja kein
kleines örtchen gemacht und deswegen
habe ich mich auch heute dafür
entschieden dass ich zwei kleine
törtchen mache ich sage euch aber
während des rezepts und während des
videos ihren wieder dazu wie jetzt auch
in einer großen vormachen können einer
großen springform wie zum beispiel einer
24 26 oder 28 der springform damit ich
die mccanns auch nicht unbedingt
abändern sondern er mir ist einfach
dieses rezept mal drei nehmen um so eine
große form zu machen
ich habe jetzt wie gesagt dieses
einfachen rezept habt es auch zwei
teilchen aufgeteilt so passt nämlich von
der menge her ideal
und jetzt bin ich schon gespannt wie ihr
euch das konzept gefällt
für den mürbeteig braucht ihr 150 gramm
butter 25 gramm zucker 1 eigelb eine
prise backpulver und eine prise salz und
ich werde das ganze in diesem fall
förmchen backen
wenn ihr das in einer großen springform
backen bolt in einer 24 26 oder 28 cm
durchmesser springform dann nimm dir
einfach die dreifache menge klasse
traten welt nicht einfach in der
maschine verrührt
eben noch den hörer hier ausgetauscht
habe ein flexiblerer genommen weil es
mit dem viel besser geht also dieser
mürbeteig lässt sich in der thermomix am
besten verkneten
jetzt habe ich hier meine zwei förmchen
bereits mit butter aus gestrichenen mehl
bestreut nehme ich mir hier meines teig
kneten einmal stellen zudem bald
zusammen
die butter muss richtig schön kalt sein
und wenn jetzt zeit hab dann wasser den
teig am besten noch im kühlschrank eine
halbe stunde ruhen
bei mir muss es schneller gehen und
möglichst eigentlich am besten wenn man
den wirklich über nacht in den
kühlschrank stellen so dass sich der
zucker richtig schön drin lösen kann
ihr könnt aber auch puderzucker nehmen
ich habe jetzt vergessen noch
zitronenschale in den teig zu reiben
dass die traditionell das gibt dem teils
ein schönes aroma und frisch ist dann
freue mich darauf so eine kleine rolle
und teile die in zwei hälften
jetzt kann ich jeweils die förmchen
damit auskleiden
es waren übrigens zwei herz förmchen die
ich mal bei tchibo gekauft habe wir
haben da echt ganz tolle back produkte
jedes mal wenn ich da bin zu schlagen
und dieses süße pärchen sind echt ganz
toll und dann nehmt euch einfach eine
gabel und sticht damals ein damit der
webtrekk schön flach bleibt und ich gebe
den mürbeteig jetzt so noch mal für etwa
zehn minuten in den kühlschrank
mal ein bisschen kalt werden kann und
bereitet so lange die ezb vor
hier habe ich jetzt meine stimme das
sind 200 gramm
dieses mal sind es frische zwetschen in
beiden shows gelten kann hatte ich
tiefgekühlte macht aber keinen
unterschied
und hier habe ich noch etwas zwetschgen
wasser etwa ein halbes schnapsglas voll
also zwei esslöffel die des zwetschgen
wasser könnte aber auch weglassen und da
kommt noch etwas zitronensaft mit rein
falls ihr die große menge machen wollen
also diesen großen kuchen nimmt auch wie
hier einfach die dreifache menge und
hier muss man eben die zwetschgen noch
in steinen
wenn ihr die aus dem tiefkühlfach habt
sind dir schon entstand da könnte dann
zu 150 gramm nehmen das wird auch
reichen die zwetschken werden jetzt
gewürfelt und ich mache das jetzt
einfach ganz schnell in meinem leiser
reiser
einen schönen gleichmäßigen würfel
da kommt auch das zwetsch dem wasser mit
rein und noch etwas zitronensaft dann
tue ich das ganz kurz und lass das jetzt
einfach so stinkt damit das bisschen
durchziehen kann
mein weg ist jetzt schön kalt den werde
ich jetzt bei 200 grad ober unterhitze
etwas vor backen damit er eben schild
durch ist bevor da eben dann die
zwetschgen und die weser musste darauf
kommt ich werde ihn so etwa 10 minuten
backen
einfach so dass er nicht dunkel wird
sondern einfach etwas an gebacken wird
kurz bevor ihr dann den teig aus dem
ofen nehmen könnt ihr schon mal die b&c
masse vorbereiten
dazu braucht ihr einen eiweiß 25 gramm
kristallzucker 25 gramm puderzucker und
einen teelöffel stärke also speisestärke
und auch hinter die menge mal drei
nehmen wenn ihr den großen kuchen backen
wollt dann klickt ihr das eiweiß in eine
rührschüssel und was das steif schlagen
fast steif ist lasst ihr den
kristallzucker ein riese und richtig
schön fest werden
richtig schöne bestattermeister habt
müsst ihr dann rest mit hand unterheben
also ist hier richtig diese spitze
so muss die hoch stehen dann ist schnell
richtig schon fest
und ich muss sagen das klappt mit
kitchenette einfach am besten ich hab
noch nie so einen festen eischnee mit
ein antrag gerät hingekriegt oder
geschweige denn oder anderen
küchenmaschinen und jetzt werde ich hier
noch bruder zucker und stärke rein 7
einfach kurz untergehoben das solltet
ihr nicht mit dem gerät machen
hier seht ihr die kleinen törtchen die
sind am rand schon etwas leicht braun
also noch brauner sollten sie nicht
werden
die habe ich einen spritzbeutel den
geber in glas gestürzt hat und da gibt
es einen ganz einfachen trick dass das
da unten jetzt nicht gleich raus läuft
ich kenne hier einfach ein bisschen vom
spritzbeutel rein
ich geb dir darüber in welcher dann
läuft da unten auch nix raus
ihr könnt es aber auch ganz gut einfach
mit einem löffel dann über den kuchen
verteilen
ihr müsst nicht auf spritzen aber so
könnte eben ein schönes muster noch
drauf machen noch meine zwetschken hier
drin verteilen und jetzt sehe ich hier
das stück raus und kann gebetshaus
herunterdrücken die wetter dann einfach
drauf gespitzt und zu sehen dann die
törtchen aus wie ihr sehen könnt habe
ich hier keine lücken gelassen der bc
ist richtig schön gleichmäßig über den
zweck stadt verteilt aber auch nicht bis
zum rand ich möchte nämlich nicht dass
später der bg an meinem arm einer
springform kleben bleibt so wenn ich das
ganze jetzt bei 150 oder 160 grad
nochmal backen
ich denke da braucht so nochmal etwa 25
30 minuten und dann zeige ich euch das
ergebnis nach 30 minuten sehen meine
zwetschgen jetzt so aus sie haben jetzt
eine schöne kruste bekommen weil der pc
einfach schön langsam trocknen konnte
und backen konnte so laut ich jetzt
einfach abkühlen und wetter an den rand
abtreten
ein fertiges zwetschken törtchen aus
also das ist jetzt noch ein bisschen war
habe ich schneide jetzt trotzdem mal an
und zugucken wie das aussieht ich habe
das selbst auch noch nie probiert
ich habe keine ahnung wie das schmeckt
ich denke da wird auch ganz gut zimt
reinpassen also über die zitrone
weglässt daneben mit zimt also von innen
aus und jetzt eben noch der
geschmackstest also hier nochmal die
ansicht von ihrem gespannt
das ergebnis ist ein seltsamer tag mit
diesen zitronenaroma die zwetschen und
sind richtig schön sauer und dann diese
süße pc haube also passt wirklich sehr
gut und ihr könnt natürlich dieses
gericht auch mit anderen obstsorten
machen ihr könnt auch rhabarber benutzen
also das ist praktisch auf so meinen
rhabarberkuchen rezept da habe ich das
im sommer eben auch ganz gerne mit
rhabarber gemacht und ich muss sagen
dass mir das wirklich sehr gut schmeckt
ich denke winter passt ganz gut sind mit
rein
ihr könnt es auch ganz gut mit äpfeln
machen oder mit nektarinen oder mit
pfirsichen mit kirschen also je nachdem
was ihr habt und ich wünsche euch jetzt
viel spaß beim nachbacken ich hoffe das
rezept gefällt euch genauso gut wie mir
und wir sehen uns beim nächsten mal
wieder mit einem anderen video bis bald
ein